obviously i haven't filmed in a really
long time
and um i'm just grateful to be back on
youtube and i'm really excited for you
guys to watch this video
olivia jade makes her return to youtube
more than
a year since her last video was posted
in 2019.
that clip came in the wake of her
family's involvement in the 2019
college admissions scandal good morning
everybody
i am so excited to be vlogging you have
no clue no okay glue i'm so excited i
could cry
the 21 year old takes viewers through
her day i just finished
my little notes and planning and morning
that's supposed to be good for you i
don't even know if i can work she also
tells fans that if they have any
questions about
why she's back on the platform they
should watch her episode of red table
talk
just for my own mental sanity i don't
want to keep rehashing things i just
want to move on and do better and move
forward and come back
and do what i love which is youtube so
you don't have to watch nobody's forcing
you
but i didn't want that to be misread
okay enjoy of course the college
admissions scandal sent both laurie
lachlan and her husband
massimo to prison lori has since been
released
while massimo is currently behind bars
now amid olivia's return to youtube a
source tells e.t
the whole family is quote trying their
best to move forward
the source adds quote olivia hopes that
her fans can see how she has grown from
this experience both personally and
professionally she is excited about this
new chapter of her career and is ready
to put the past behind her
and hopes others can do the same
although i can't change the past
i can change how i act and what i do
going forward
um i just didn't want anybody to take it
the wrong way and it seemed like i was
being like
i i went on my table and now my name's
cleared like no
that's not it i want them to be happy so
i want to be supportive of everything
they want to do
a source previously told et that laurie
is also
excited and hopeful about getting her
career
back on track i'm really sorry that this
happened or i really
own that this was a big mess up on
everybody's part but i think everybody
feels that way
in my family right now
you